quem já ouviu falar de um caso da
denúncia e quando é salva por assédio
sexual em moçambique
quem já ouviu falar de um caso de
denúncia e com deleção por assédio
sexual e moçambique 11 através da
resposta da década num país onde há
situações de violação sexual violência
doméstica ainda é um grande desafio
presente instituições de justiça o que
dizer em lançar o assédio sexual não é
de qualquer forma bem haja um mito um
ano depois do seu surgimento eu sou cada
vez mais os direitos humanos das
mulheres no mundo e os ventos se
espalham por todo mundo cada um é sua
ansiedade mas eu sempre penso khan algo
que pode ser adaptado e sobretudo para o
contexto uns amiga
vejamos o mito pressupõe o grito de uma
vila e réplica de outras vítimas
mas antes disso pressupõe instituições
que possam tramitar este processo até
chamada justiça que as vítimas querem
imagine-se neste processo não existam
estas instituições ou se existem essas
instituições mas os atores que lhe deram
essas instituições são insensíveis
movimento puxa morre
como entender o papel
o comportamento destes atores
insensíveis
eu vejo em 3 paradigmas o agravamento os
agravados do assédio sexual em
moçambique o primeiro pobreza estrutural
segundo vulnerabilidade terceiro cultura
de impunidade
vou começar com a primeira distrito como
colas província não pula encontrei o
senhor a todos com sua filha de 14 anos
e o seu neto mais novo de um mês numa
instituição da justiça que entra por uma
sala
um homem de 40 anos tinha
abusado engravidar da sua filha na
altura tinha 13 anos e eu iria interpor
ação
eu fiquei satisfeita na qualidade de
jornalista era raro ver aquela situação
comunidades mais próximas
os sistemas de justiça formais mais do
que isso um pai preocupado com os
direitos da sua filha
amazing aproximam senhor perguntei o que
o senhor pretendo com esta só eu disse
eu quero que este homem se casa com a
minha filha eu bicho tem duas mulheres
seis filhos não podem assumir a minha
filha e o seu sétimo filho eu quero que
as instituição brigas que o homem casar
se com a minha filha eu fiquei escada
o homem disse eu sou pobre eu sou o
camponês fifa da agricultura eu não está
em condições de criar os meus dez filhos
e as duas mulheres
e quanto mais esta filha e mais um metro
está a dar-me agora estou a mãe tem que
assumir
fiquei gelada mas era compreensível o
senhor era camponês com cerca de 90 por
cento daquela população vive da
agricultura
o direito não cola gente pros distritos
com indicadores de desenvolvimento mais
baixos é um distrito com clima seco não
chove ea agricultura não é produtiva
o senhor não tinha outra forma de
rendimento só pra ver os níveis de
pobreza dados do governo de 2014 revelo
98% da população de que o distrito vivia
em pelotas ou casas precárias
isto quer dizer que apenas 12% daquela
população tenha casas condenadas
vou falar com uma população de 350 mil
habitantes
é muita pureza a próxima mina na
verdadeira vontade do pai que se casar
qual seria o desejo dela perguntei na
que é que isto quer dizer que o país
está a tentar entregar todo o casamento
quero que tu que tens a dizer que se
calhar pudesse ajudar ela disse eu quero
ir ao lar é complicado ouvir isso mas eu
pensei que ela não tivesse percebido com
algumas das meninas até 7ª classe não
fala muito bem português e tem
explorá-la quer seja na lista como eu
talvez professora e enfermeira ela disse
não não eu quero e rolar eu eo meu filho
perguntei a ela em que circunstâncias
tenha conhecido o pai do seu filho e ela
disse 'eu interceptavam quando voltava
da escola e oferecia mais pobreza e
pobreza extrema
eu tinha dinheiro para poder sustentar
lá pra poder alimentá la
ela passava fome em casa ela não teve
voz para dizer mito e essa
vulnerabilidade não termina em casa na
escola
um estudo do centro de capacitação da
sociedade civil sérgio revelou que no
ano passado mais de metade das alunas
além de sangue que foi vítima de assédio
nas escolas
estamos a falar de alunos que têm notas
baixas em faltas e que se tornam
vulneráveis a professores e diretores da
escola e funcionários
muitas vezes os encarregados não sabem
dessa situação
eu tenho poder de excluir las com salas
da escola sun balas
elas não têm autoridade para dizer mito
muitas vezes não existe um órgão dentro
das escolas que possa ouvir hoje isso
não pára por aqui no mercado trabalha
sadia continua
quando ela vai para o emprego vai para o
processo de acesso é o principal
critério de avaliação não é a
competência sexo lésbico e muitas vezes
até quando consegue um emprego a uma
outra batalha para progredir na carreira
em sujeitar-se não perde o emprego
como é que nós vamos fazer com esta
cultura de impunidade será que estamos
perdidas
onde é que nós vamos gritar a uma
solução
eu sou uma sobrevivente
não porque tenha crescido na capital com
os privilégios que toda a gente sabe mas
porque usa uma fórmula 1 a fórmula da
prevenção
é verdade que nós não podemos controlar
a mente dos abusadores e travar os
avanços sexuais em qualquer contexto mas
eu pude usar esta fórmula como prevenção
em todo este percurso desde a escola
primária a competência durante o período
da escola sempre procurei esforçar na e
ter melhor desempenho para não ficar
vulnerável 10ª classe dispensei o bloco
de ciências que era muito difícil
estudar duas três vezes mais do que os
colegas mais inteligente 12ª classe
passei como é de atores não foi fácil
foram noites sem dormir bloqueava as
festas todas mas eu consegui ter esse
desempenho querem saber mais durante
todo este ciclo estudantil
nunca houve nenhum professor nenhum
diretor
o funcionário da escola vira técnico eu
fui à casa das minhas colegas passaram
por esta situação foi o mercado de
trabalho acabou assada ou não assédio
sexual sempre foi o primeiro critério da
inicial o leão vai ser problema para se
conseguir passar não por esta via mas
passei por situações dramáticas de
assédio sexual por duas vezes teve que
demitir do meu time porque não tive onde
interpor a minha queixa isso não foi
para mim um prejuízo de uma ti mas
imediatamente o mercado absorveu por
causa das competências que tinha
agregado durante todo o mês
site são as mesmas competências como
fizeram ganhar prêmios internacionais
dos prémios cnn ou outro mas foi muito
trabalho
as mesmas competências como fizeram hoje
falar para várias universidades não só
em sangue mas por exemplo em boston nos
estados unidos e lá defende a equipe da
de oportunidades para a mulher
não há necessidade de cotas não queremos
ser integradas por favor nós queremos
ser integradas via do contencioso e
ocupará que os lugares vazios
não faz sentido que um país com cerca de
52 por cento mulheres o poder ainda
esteja mais organizado e se calhar seja
por via disso nas escolas numa política
contra sexo nascimento nos trabalhos ou
seja vários setores de trabalho não
temos políticas contra o assédio sexual
mas por via desta arma com potência eu
pude dizer not me não eu
eu não serei vítima eu não serei vítima
fatal numa situação vamos saber como em
vários países em desenvolvimento onde as
instituições ainda não está uma dura ou
não a sensibilidade em relação a essas
matérias é preciso adotar uma arma de
prevenção e esta é a competência vai
ditar a prevenção de vários outros casos
de assédio sexual movido a competência
nós vamos conseguir alcançar os órgãos
de tomada de decisão
vamos conseguir aprovar políticas contra
sexo lindérrima
vamos conseguir operacionalizar todos os
setores seja judicial seja de apoio
moral e psicológico para que todas as
meninas que possam que passem por essa
situação possam ter força e suporte para
dizer
mito mas antes disso temos que ser
competente ea minha fórmula é
competência e daí devemos dizer em nota
o me não eu eu não serei vítima
não defendo o mito porque não funciona
aqui mas a minha defesa é not
william
[Aplausos]
[Música]